he knows his lane feet inside
shot clock winding down engrams on a
pull-up contested shop cornet right in
his face and he nails it if you're not a
play the way they want to play and that
is last year they were third in the
league and he seems to be in the right
place nose really open very good there
is nice move without the ball see he's
easy if his man hesitates and steps away
from him to look to help out on a
dribbler
he's moving without the ball quickly
they've got a budding star when
Williamson comes back the Rockets they
got to go into the second half of the
season last year they took off last year
deep three Lonzo ball straight away and
he did not succeed beyond the arc last
93m 12 led Russell's shoot that one out
there
beautiful
there's the Pasolini ones oh boy that's
it Lonzo you can knock that three-point
shot down but that's what he was drafted
to be so excellent feed by Lonzo ball
but you're big in a position to be
successful it'll be more points off a
turnover or at least a missed
opportunity and turnover Warriors
guiltily williams go in the distance
grace 9th assist the grandma agree with
6 points 9 assists incredible that's
like Plastic Man
series witness man today yeah that is
impressive
Joe Ingram boy to the free-throw line he
leads the bells with 40 through to paint
room gets to it back door they want you
to play attack them and collapse their
defense and forced in the guards force a
lot do that no very efficient drew
Albany the size Brandon Ingram all the
way into the foul line and this
three-point shot as well this is what
takes you to another level offensive
so I go back and I watch that game and
you know it was really impressive about
her inside a tenth of the shot clock
monk blocked away Derrick Favors
he was defending to that time with
beyond bow on the cut one of the keys to
start the game was using your defense
and allowing that to start to office
Gharib favors in the passing lane
there's no one on the floor for gotta go
the Oklahoma City Thunder
dr. guard Brandon English no one that
can guard Brandon Ingram right now and
he knows that about the 4 for 21
performance that he had against the
Lakers and he is aggressive tonight I
love it
songs on TV boys for almost 50 years now
and he is just he loves be
[Music]
[Applause]
not a traditional tongue put it that way
no one a traditional because he jumping
over dude that's six foot ten to 80 yeah
I like the that's impressive that is
impressive
grows off the ice cream with Boris
looking for another triple quick quick
decision and looked at some great we're
like that that's just sick
Dutch therefore he knew when he knew
where he was grabbing that rebound he
knew what that ball was gone
excellent delivery by Lanza bold move
[Applause]
will hire on the catch and shoot threes
like that Lonzo ball mid-range game
Terrence Ross Gotham Lugosi era Jackson
gets it corner three now bring it back
out wing three six weeks ago with the
knee surgery it was down now if your
Lonzo now you're taking mental data at
what they're doing they're down to 49
percent after they were sizzling in the
first quarter you know drink the floor
on me get your feet set and get ready to
knock it down
that's 17 for Lonzo ball to pace the
pals let's see how it goes to the second
24 minutes you'll never forget you'll
never forget and I'll fire grateful and
I say a big thank you Tim for his impact
that he's had on my line Derrick Favors
coming over to apply the pick and a
little floater start against Jews
especially with the emotion to this game
way back one in 2011
[Applause]
they collaborate
[Applause]
Ingram fakes now on a pull-up got it
Brandon Ingram continues his role a
Pierce what a breakout season Brandon
Ingram has had 7 of 9 from the field
he's got 17 and the pelicans six-point
lead after two quarters here at the
gardening
[Music]
whatever they want home isn't it guys
got a decent handle boy does he now
Ingram at the buzzer
yeah seen that before for the Australian
fireman's that the relief effort in
Australia Ingram on the run Ingram hop
against O'Neill they'll get it to
Brandon Brandon with two on the clock
for the win
[Applause]
catch and shoot as we watch the replay I
said you would
that's what we say in the beginning of
the game because the way that you talk
down guard that pick-and-roll Brandon
Ingram understands you can put the boys
O'Neal on me
you can put back down a bit told me you
can put joe ingles on me I can feel get
to my spot and elevate he has been
fantastic 15 and even better in the
second half here's Williamson facing the
double-team against the elite defenses
and in the playoff series if you don't
have enough time so call it a block
we're covering against Derek white
there's a lot of
five straight rookie moving forward the
ability to stretch the defense we
already know I think Nico Mele is
feminine form
airs on between now he goes up and gets
the basketball in he's really gifted
41st overall Tim Conway
[Applause]
here's Paula the way inside design
williamson over the top of smart got it
back over tights and one now right there
you saw what this man is all about
covers and gets the rebound
that's hot but he has quick feet jumping
ability now once he gets down you see
that quick spin move that side out of
bounds New Orleans comfortable here
today there is zc he was at the top of
the circle he ran that loop his
defensive man got caught had no idea
where the ball was right and then the
pass is right into the middle of before
you better go get him he set a good
screen on offense
[Applause]
Williamson look at this though
and scene came all the way from another
left-wing to get that ball he has such
confidence that he can out-jump anyone
eight on the shot clock so clear out
nine so Paul yeah he knows Sept of nine
four four from beyond the arc good right
now he should be the free throw line
Lonzo Paul with eight on the shot clock
so racket start offensive listen do you
have member I say this all the time he
is one of one a lot of basketball and
given the pills Stewart for secessionist
good luck Brandon Ingram wanted to go
inside he will it'll be Zion what is
Westbrook from the foul line can't get
it and rebounded by ball who is
averaging about six boards per game it's
the rim and the entire stanchion is
still moving expects ayam Williamson
initially to be a force in transition
any time he's in space this is what he's
capable of but just watch the rim in the
aftermath of this finish first of all
perfectly placed past the only guy who
could catch that was Lanza was a great
challenge defensively just watch the rim
moving at the end of this to get some
sense of the force it's always
fascinating to me to watch Redick just
move just track his movements on either
side anger a little reverse wanna finish
by Brandon Ingram
[Applause]
[Music]
Andale intruder almost threw it away
Nader knows clock is down don't stop the
denial then donator is gonna have to
make Zion pay at this end that's gonna
be tough six tenths of a second enough
time to catch it and shoot defensive
coverage spy Derrick Favors standard
open right now drew it favors instead
Lanza looking for it
[Applause]
here's alonso shot where is shrewder no
[Applause]
gotta see his feet as he hit the deck
[Music]
just like a you day
12 the rim the man many he came to see
up top for Zion Simeon legacy that
carries on in Kendrick okay
Williamson from his AAU team a job look
at this path let's see here
this is the food's raining down at the
Windy City right now they all start we
come out here just beat everybody around
the league and the two headliners nice
gracious I'm making some highlight just
snuck it over the rim Ingram off the
dribble heat inside not a perfect pass
that Williamson another dunk Terry stops
once timeout a sign of great improvement
by a natural score to get everything out
of everybody but also he just signed a
10-day just a few hours ago
so the Warriors want to take every
chance they can get you evaluated
got the triple
is dead form on the three again you see
the advancement of the basketball pool
three oh hey whoa whoa whoa hold on hold
on that's a nice shot the secondary ball
handler the way the ball moves to see
Danny Green coming back on the floor the
first quarter accounted an Ingram time
it just kind of lost out of his hands he
his hand did come off of the ball it
didn't stay connected so if they don't
call it it's not a foul is not it but
it's a basket for Ingram
[Music]
here's a room for three over green it's
gone
including this three-pointer look at
that release point like Danny Green is a
very good defender but that that close
is slow vlogabond
looks like hard hat favors that time
instead ball penetrates floats it off
the window
of all with 17 nine
in the third quarter our second quarter
in alonzo into the quarter gotta be
honest
[Applause]
that is almost a full quart long man's
ass right here this is not an easy pass
to mate at three-quarter court on time
on target you want to talk about trust
almost stolen by George Magoffin throws
it and they tell you as a guard to
always throw it to the corner of the
backboard got to go into the shot clock
I guess that's high percentage favors
staying with it but that's two looks at
the PALS couldn't tap it all tough break
that was exactly my